so i'm starting today with a warning and
i think this is an important one and
this is a warning to my fellow
do something leftists you know trump
talks about the do nothing left
i care about the do something left i've
always cared about
getting things done and the warning is
as follows
do not allow the right and in particular
the trumpian right to make the next
three and a half months
up until the presidential election about
these culture war topics that they're
increasingly trying to use to distract
from the policy failures of this
administration
and to distract from the governance
failures of this administration now
i'm including in this the trump
administration itself
trumpists but also the republicans who
maybe they're not vocally pro-trump
but they've stood aside and allowed
donald trump to do essentially whatever
he wants
they've rubber stamped the judges and to
really understand this we've got to do a
little bit of homework so first of all
when we talk about culture war we're
talking about
cultural conflict we're not talking
about policy battles
right we're talking about a value a
battle over whose values are going to
reign supreme
and these are also often these culture
war battles
they're often over issues where there's
more disagreement than on policy
so on policy we see on health care
on abortion the country's nowhere near
united but there is
much more support on one side there's
much less
division as far as 50 50 division than
we've seen in a long time
so i should remind you there's a lot of
right wingers and even so-called
enlightened centrists who claim
the left is waging a culture war and the
right is just
desperate to get a word in edgewise or
something like that
that has never been less true than it is
now the right is
fomenting a culture war specifically
because they believe it will help them
win in november
because they can't justify their
reelections in any other way because
they failed so let's take the abortion
example for a moment
for a long time abortion was a hot
button cultural war issue and
over time american opinion about
abortion has become more and more on the
side of
in most cases abortion should be legal
that makes abortion less of an
ideal issue with which to wage
a culture war now among evangelical
conservative circles and and in
religious groups
being against abortion is still a pretty
good way to raise money for your
campaign but
abortion has become a less efficient way
to polarize people
to your advantage right now everything
we're seeing
when it comes to sports team names
confederate flags
confederate monuments protesters being
peaceful
versus violent and to what degree uh uh
is it one or the other and to what
degree do we need to give police
deference
these are all fomenting a culture
war which does not favor the left in
this election cycle even coronavirus has
actually become a cultural war issue
specifically when it comes to masks as a
proxy for this ideology of freedom and
liberty and don't tread on me
there's actually a debate to be had over
for example
which statues should come up should come
down
and which statues should stay up which
names should be cleansed from history
and which should be allowed to stand
reasonable people can disagree about
you know where is the line between
taking down a statue or what constitutes
an offensive sports team name
but the problem is that for the next
three and a half months it is a complete
distraction from policy and which policy
platform we are voting for
nobody gets health care if your george
washington statue
stays up but the robert e lee statue
comes down
reasonable people can disagree but that
doesn't get anybody health care
the washington redskins changing their
name
does nothing to improve education in any
way
but it allows the right wing to continue
parroting this idea of
woke leftist mob spreading cancel
culture
they are losing like they've never lost
before on policy and governance
with the exception of getting a bunch of
judges confirmed and that also doesn't
get enough attention
while we're arguing about confederate
flags now i've played
clips for you over the last few days
weeks
where donald trump has been asked about
his biggest first term accomplishments
and his second term agenda and he can
barely answer those questions
that alone should disqualify trump from
a second term but that gets less
attention
when they can make this about we're
fighting a culture of
marxism which of course doesn't exist or
cancel culture or whatever they want to
talk about
now where this gets difficult is that
corporate media plays into this
corporate media will stage these debates
with people with particularly extreme
positions on these issues
person a says keep every confederate
statue
person b says take down every statue
including george washington because he
owns slaves
and it is wasted time it's wasted time
number one
because most people don't hold such
extreme views like most americans i
think
actually would be pretty reasonable and
they'd say well there's a difference
between someone
known for fighting to keep slavery in
this country or else
they will leave the union versus george
washington is really known
for other things including saying we
need a president not a king etc
and slavery was a sign of the times it
doesn't excuse slavery but most people
would understand the difference there so
the debates in media are set up
with people with the most extreme views
and it only serves to
distract from the historic failures
we've seen
from the current administration on
coronavirus
on foreign policy on education
on trade on health care etc they win
when the conversation is about flags and
statues
because it hides that they've face
planted on every important issue for the
last three and a half years so what we
need to do
is keep the focus on policy from now
until november third trump's polling has
imploded
for three major reasons his handling of
coronavirus
his handling of the economy in the
context of coronavirus relative to other
countries
and his insane reactions his
authoritarian reactions
to the george floyd protest he's failed
to deliver
on just about every campaign promise the
united states is a global laughing stock
those are the issues we should talk
about the failures there
and joe biden as an alternative and put
aside these cultural issues because
they benefit from the discussion being
about
flags and statues rather than
about their policy failures so this
next story is just more funny than
anything else because
we are obviously not going to see donald
trump's tax returns
but remember how donald trump has been
saying since 2015
that if it were up to him he would show
us his taxes
but they're under audit if and when
they're ever
no longer under audit he's going to
release his tax returns now
that never made sense anybody who could
think critically realized it never made
sense because obviously
not all of his recent tax returns would
permanently be under audit
and of course audits don't last years
and years but in any case
it was an excuse trump gave for not
showing his taxes
his personal attorney rudy giuliani
maybe it's his former personal attorney
at this point i don't know
he went on fox news and he said listen
there's got to be finality here
trump's taxes have been audited and it's
been closed
and we're moving on you can't now again
congress or investigators ask for
trump's taxes
he's indirectly saying we need a final
point on this because the whole audit
thing has been closed up well if the
audits are done let's see the tax
returns right
here is rudy giuliani himself saying it
they've been audited and it's fine and
these are now closed
matters as far as he's concerned could
make the argument that they have no
particularized need for it
you could also make the argument that
they are not investigating any
particularized crime
they have no reason to believe that
there's anything wrong with this tax
returns
i mean all these tax returns have been
by and large maybe not the last one but
all of them have been audited
all of them have been either uh passed
on or settled
and there should be some finality in
your tax returns
in other words we get audited we make a
deal we pay the government
you don't come after me forever for that
and also this is the president united
states
there are literally 400 4 000
prosecutors who can now come after his
records
i don't think the court ever thought of
that all these tax returns
have been audited and there should be
finality
rudy says you know you get audited you
make a deal
and that's it he is saying there that
the issue of the tax returns
is over because trump is no longer under
audit
and he has moved on he's saying you do
the audit the
audit ends and that's it you don't keep
looking at the same returns that have
been audited
he's admitting that the audits are done
if they ever existed
now maybe even more interesting there is
rudy saying
trump's audits aren't just done
but they've been settled when rudy says
that they've been settled it implies
again you know talk about self-inflicted
damage you settle audits and pay fines
when you've done something wrong on your
tax returns and rudy giuliani there
again just as an aside seems to say
not only are the audits done but they've
been resolved sometimes you know you pay
a fine and you move on
which seems to be an admission that
donald trump has been
deceptive enough on his tax returns you
know you can always claim
it was a mistake but that he has had to
pay fines
or make good or settle with the irs when
it comes to his taxes
it's stunning that this is not getting
more attention
it's stunning that a lot of people used
to respect rudy giuliani and again the
the
reminder is we're not going to see the
tax returns right
to be super clear trump was never going
to release the tax returns
the supreme court's decision isn't going
to get them released before the election
uh and the important thing for us is we
don't need to see them to know how to
vote in november it's not like we're
saying
you know i on one hand i i don't like
these things trump has done and on the
other hand
this wasn't so bad but if i could only
see the tax returns i'd be able to
decide what to do in november
take solace in that even though we're
not going to see trump's tax returns
we don't really need to we already know
what we should be doing in november when
it comes to trump versus biden and i
think that's the
if you're looking for any positive take
away from any of this
it's we've got enough information to
know how to vote in november without
seeing donald trump's tax returns
tonight join me at 8pm eastern
on youtube and twitch and facebook
for the third ever david pakman show
chess tournament
i'll be playing and streaming anybody
can play
community event no cost to play no
barrier to entry
it's completely free just register
at davidpakman.com chess that's tonight
tuesday july 14th 8 p.m eastern i will
see you then
and of course remember that you can get
the daily audio podcast
every single day right around 3 p.m
eastern
on whatever is your favorite podcasting
app spotify
itunes google play podcast
podbean if you will anyway wherever you
want to hear it you can hear it
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are james
markham
and jeff sulek thank you so much james
and jeff for your
support and also a big thank you to
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day
christina pacias has been a member for
almost five
years and is the sustainer of the day
thank you so much christina grab a
membership
support the show get the daily bonus
show and all of these other great perks
by signing up in mere
seconds at joinpackman.com
so we've got to get back to this anthony
fauci story
yesterday in 24 hours this has
completely exploded yesterday i told you
that increasingly donald trump is
listening to
people other than doctors i guess we
would say dr anthony fauci the chief
infectious disease doctor of the united
states who's been working with
presidents for 40 years in the united
states worked on the aids epidemic etc
etc
dr fauci revealed that he had not even
spoken to donald trump for what now
would be about five weeks and that he
has not briefed
donald trump on coronavirus in a serious
manner for two months
i also told you yesterday that the white
house has put out a list of things that
fauci got wrong in order i guess to
discredit him
so clearly it was going bad meanwhile
donald trump has retweeted chuck
woolery and this is continuing to
escalate i'll get to the woolery thing
momentarily but in just the 24
additional hours since yesterday's show
there now seems to be a war that this is
crazy
not between the white house and the
virus that's the war if you want to
apply war language here it should be
us versus the virus there seems to be a
war
between the white house and the
government's own
top infectious disease doctor anthony
fauci
fauci just seems to be doing medical
stuff and the world
is again crying and laughing because the
white house
is going after not the virus they're
going after fauci
dr fauci good for him is no longer
mincing words he said very clearly
the reason cases are exploding is
because we never completely shut down
and we're doing the wrong things
states that really came down were fully
shut down
and stayed closed longer others opened
too early here's the full quote from dr
fauci
we did not shut down entirely and that's
the reason why we went up we started to
come down and then we plateaued at a
level that was really quite high
about 20 000 infections a day then as we
started to reopen we're seeing the
surges that we're seeing today as we
speak
we made a set of guidelines a few months
ago unfortunately
it did not work very well for us we can
get a handle on that
i am really confident we can if we step
back understand that to avoid having to
fully shut down again
which it looks like some states are
starting to do you
have to pull back for a while you have
to really
limit things what is going to turn
around the case explosion in arizona
texas california and florida
if you don't shut now shut down
california has extended a shutdown
to 30 counties now including la county
in six weeks hopefully we will see the
positive effect of that it takes a while
these other states are barely doing a
thing what will turn it around
the heat hasn't turned it around you
know whatever
else they said was going to turn it
around has not meanwhile
instead of working with dr fauci the
white house
is now fully on the offensive against dr
fauci the guy who worked 40 years under
republican and democratic presidents
whose ideology is health
he is the target of trump's attack he is
the target of the white house's
opposition research the white house
released a document to media outlets
meant to make dr fauci look
untrustworthy with a list of things
fauci got wrong
notice trump got wrong in april in march
actually we have 15 cases which will
soon
be zero fauci is reportedly referred to
by some at the white house
as dr doom and gloom apparently fauci is
not
pleasant enough about 140 000 people
dying
fauci isn't upbeat about 60 to 70
000 new cases a day another report
alleges that donald trump is reportedly
rattled
by the fact that the country continues
to trust dr fauci
more than they trust trump on
coronavirus you know we talk about
ignorance in this country a lot the
country doesn't seem so ignorant
that they would trust the reality show
host president over
dr fauci on matters of infectious
disease and
part of this is we know trump doesn't
like anybody else getting positive
attention
but it gets even crazier because donald
trump's director of social media dan
scavino
posted a pejorative cartoon about dr
fauci
that refers to him as dr fawcett dr
fawcett who wants to turn off the faucet
on everything so to speak
so they're essentially attacking dr
fauci
i guess because he's being too cautious
essentially the white house seems to be
attacking dr
fauci for not being more fun
about 140 000 u.s deaths a number that
in all likelihood
in the next few days is going to start
accelerating more quickly as we saw it
do during the week days last week
the white house has gone to war not with
the virus
but with the doctor fighting the virus
so
what i suggest what i think we have to
do is we have to step back here
um recognize that this is part of the
ant
anti-intellectualism in this country
where
you can only trick the population
into continuing to just live a
completely normal life as if nothing is
going on
when you have a lot of uneducated and
uninformed and ignorant people and while
on the one hand it's good that dr
fauci is still more trusted than trump
because the virus
spreads virally even if only 15
20 25 30 of the country thinks it's fine
to just do whatever the hell you want
that's enough to perpetuate one of the
worst
uh trajectories when it comes to cases
in the world now secondly the idea
that we've just had too much shutdown we
can't tolerate it anymore
recall that many states never shut down
fully
because there was no national shutdown
trump insists
oh i shut it down and now i'm opening it
back up trump never shut it down it was
states that decided what they had to do
and many of them barely shut down
we might now actually need a national
shutdown if things don't turn around
we're going to talk uh also later today
about trump's failings in terms of
polling in texas
but once again this could have been a
political windfall for donald trump he
just had to say listen we're in it
together listen to the doctors it's
going to be tough but this is what we
have to do
i trust the doctors let's do what they
say we'd be better off fewer people
would have died
donald trump would be cruising to
re-election right now very different
scenario
five months into coronavirus that we
actually see and now donald trump
has been relegated to retweeting
conspiracy theories
from game show hosts let's talk about
that next so
donald trump is the perennial victim
according to him right
he is now retweeting the conspiracy
theory from former love connection host
chuck woolery
that his own cdc is lying about
coronavirus in order to hurt trump's
chances at re-election
now i don't know about you i'm sick and
tired of trump constantly being the
victim guy who's been wealthy his whole
life
was handed a business thanks to his
dad's money his president of the us
from his rhetoric you would believe that
he was the biggest victim there is
except he's the most privileged person
there is and now there's a conspiracy
theory which was put on twitter
to start with by former game show host
chuck woolery trump retweeted it and the
way it goes is quote
the most outrageous lies are the ones
about covid19
everyone is lying the cdc media
democrats doctors not all but most that
we are told to trust
i think it's all about the election and
keeping the economy from coming back
which is about the election i'm sick of
it then trump retweeting about
this issue of opening schools also what
chuck woolery said quote there is so
much evidence yes
scientific evidence that schools should
open this fall
it's worldwide and it's overwhelming but
no
we have a medical situation a global
hundred year pandemic
and you have a reality tv show host
president
amplifying the messages of the former
host
of the tv show love connection and what
they are amplifying
are messages that run directly counter
to what medical experts are saying
the u.s keeps breaking its own record
for new cases in a single day
the death toll is around 140 000.
remember trump said once it would be
sixty thousand maybe seventy thousand
do you get why the world is laughing at
us but also increasingly crying instead
of laughing
we've handled the virus as close to as
badly as any country out there
and in the midst of to 70
000 new cases a day a reality tv host
president retweets a game show host
republican as if they know more than the
medical community i told you earlier
the white house has released what is
essentially opposition research
on dr anthony fauci and trump is instead
of standing with the doctors
standing with chuck woolery we are a
global laughingstock and this is why i
said earlier
we can't allow them to turn the next
three and a half months into statues and
flags
this is the red alert failure now you
know in terms of the list of things
fauci got wrong and why trump is
increasingly
retweeting chuck woolery and not fouchy
about she got masks wrong that's right
fauci got asymptomatic spread wrong
fauci has corrected himself but trump
said in february our 15 cases will soon
be zero
he hasn't apologized he's not admitted
fault trump said in february case
numbers are going to go down not up he
was wrong
trump said in march were we have the
virus under control we didn't
trump said in april what about injecting
bleach and isopropyl alcohol you get the
picture so this is very very
dangerous talk the maskless followers
are making it worse
just look at what's happening in florida
look at what's happening
in arizona arguably the two worst places
in the world
to be right now i don't know what we
need to change people's minds
like do we need video of icus so so
people see
what it is that happens and what's going
on will they understand graphic video
some of these folks
i don't know but what we know is we've
got to remove him we have three and a
half months to go and at this point
chuck woolery chuck woolery we'll have
more about this
on the show's instagram page david
pakman show
on instagram the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today dan harris is the author of
meditation for fidgety skeptics and also
the book 10
happier which i read a couple years ago
i think at this point
he's also an abc news anchor who um i
mean i
i hate to say dan you're known for
anything in particular but you
you came to mindfulness after what what
i guess we
we now have determined was a panic
attack on air some years ago
that's exactly right i don't mind being
known for it at least at least not
now that i've kind of reframed it if
that if it was just
dan harris known for freaking out on the
air full stop that would
kind of suck but uh the panic attack
led me in a weird and windy way to
meditation
which has been incredibly valuable to me
um
but the story of the panic attack
basically is that i was on the air
on good morning america one warm june
morning into
of 2004. and found myself
unable to speak which is inconvenient if
you want to anchor the news
and uh after the panic attack i
uh went to a doctor who asked me a bunch
of questions and one of the questions
was do you do drugs
right and i said yeah and the the story
there is that i had spent a lot of time
as a young ambitious
correspondent in war zones after 9 11. i
was in iraq and afghanistan etc etc
and i'd come home gotten depressed and i
didn't even know i was depressed
and then blindly self-medicated with
recreational drugs and
even though i wasn't high on the air and
i wasn't even doing drugs that
frequently was enough to
change my brain chemistry per this
doctor
and so that was a big wake-up call for
me and had a lot of positive
impact and was so when this happened
when the actual acute incident happened
you believed that it was because of
other it wasn't the stress of being on
air or the fear of having a problem
speaking on air that perpetuated it it
was just sort of how the stress that was
going on elsewhere in your life
manifested
i think i think for me there are always
there had
and is uh there had been and still
is a baseline amount of nerves when it
comes to speaking publicly
right so uh but but the
the changes to my brain chemistry just
made
my ability to manage the underlying
nerves
much worse and when people
don't understand what it means to have a
panic attack because to a lot of people
who
don't don't get it it seems like well
hold on you just tell yourself you're
fine and then that's it and just
re-center in that way that's not the way
it works
no no no no i wish um
a panic you can think about as just a
malfunction
of the very useful fight or flight
impulse that we all have which we
evolved for
often when we came face to face with the
saber-tooth tiger or something like that
the brain was flooded with adrenaline uh
the body had a you know the heart starts
to race
um there are a lot of very
evolutionarily
sound things that happen in the body
that prepare us to fight or run away
in our modern context we're often having
this fight or flight
impulse triggered to one extent or
another
inappropriately in traffic in a meeting
with our boss
while on social media etc etc it doesn't
always
escalate to a panic attack but it can
create
background levels of stress that are
really corrosive to our health
in extreme cases when you have panic
disorder as i do
it can result in a full-on panic attack
where you
are it runs away it enters into um
a kind of vicious cycle where the body
is having this response
the mind freaks out in response to the
body's
response the body then gets worse the
mind gets worse the body gets worse the
mind gets worse and off we go
into uh out of the zone of stress and
into the zone of panic
i i want to be careful in how i ask this
question and this applies to me as much
as it applies to you but
how much of a predisposition to this
could be
i don't know if i want to say cultural
or
i mean listen jewish neuroticism is
something that in my family
right i mean i think we you know what
i'm getting at here which is there's a
lot about
upbringing there's a lot about
expectations there's all of this baggage
that people
tend to arrive as adults with that comes
from
earlier in life could there be cultural
components to predisposition to some
degree
look i'm not an expert on this stuff i'm
half jewish
uh i was raised my dad's jewish my
mother's
uh a wasp and it's a little bit like
that movie annie hall if you've ever
seen woody allen
yeah in that movie uh uh and so
my dad had an expression that he used
which was the price of security
is insecurity this is kind of a
veneration of anxiety
um and you know i i for a variety of
reasons
anxiety is quite common among jewish
people
um i think there there may be something
very powerful to the argument
that uh historic persecution um
can lead to a hyper vigilance um and
that gets handed down
inter-generationally so i think there's
a lot going on there
plus you have the the jewish cultural
trait of really wanting to to be
successful
and so i think if you combine all of
that which by the way was there on the
other side of my on the non-jewish side
of my family tree as well
and by the way if you look at my family
tree it's just filled with a lot of
people who
have depression and or addiction
so it's a pretty ripe environment in my
case for
you know freaking out there's a debate
that exists and i've interviewed people
on both sides of it including speaking
to folks like johan hari who has written
about
anxiety and depression anyway there's
this debate about like how much of this
is physiological
how much of it is something that has
become more common because of sort of
western
society that includes it doesn't have to
be just
apps and phones it doesn't have to be
getting ahead or or keeping up with the
joneses but sort of like this package of
realities
that that exist do you have any insight
into that
from what you've experienced are these
all factors maybe to different degrees
for different people
yeah i like johann hari um i've had him
on my podcast and
as i understand i'm gonna try to my
apologies to johan if i
reproduce his thesis unfaithfully but
my understanding is his argument is yes
there are
physiological uh
genealogical factors uh too
that can contribute to things like
depression but
the way we've structured society
he argues is actually perhaps an even
bigger
contributor he talks about junk values
we have junk food we also have junk
values and the value of
individualism which he argues we've
taken too far in western culture where
it's all about the myth of the rugged
individual
divorced from the incredible wellspring
of
uh of rel interconnection and human
relationship and community
and when community withers when our
emphasis on relationships withers
we get stuck in loneliness and
solipsism and that can lead to
depression and in my case i would say
it's all of that i want to get to the
meditation
piece and mindfulness piece in a second
but a couple other things just to touch
on first
so all these videos now are going viral
of you know the stuff the costco's
and the people saying they're not going
to wear masks and confrontations that
are just completely horrifying in
a number of different ways and like
politic i have my political view of of
it
but then also politics aside these are
this is just clear these are people who
are not in a good place
in a bunch of different ways more than
likely that go beyond just your view
about
masks do you see any of the
panic type elements in
some of these these rants where people
seem to be almost like outside of their
own bodies
acting in ways that they claim they
never have in public settings
i i i see so much in this uh
in these videos um i see the panic
or sort of uh you know losing being
hijacked by the reptilian folds of your
brain by the
by the what's called the amygdala the
stress center of the brain
so i see that i see again this myth of
individualism where we don't have any
responsibility to our neighbors
and i see a kind of twisting of
masculinity
because in particular at least one study
shows that men are more likely to resist
mask wearing than women and and
and you know i'm i don't know how i feel
about the term toxic masculinity
uh just because i feel like it sometimes
gets um
used in a really finger-wagging way and
i'm not big on finger wagging
but i i do think that it we are
due for a rethink of masculinity which
has
often been you know rejecting
what anybody tells me what to do
rejecting being in touch
with your emotions and in fact this idea
and i say this is a guy who never wanted
to be in touch with his emotions
ever at all and had thought it was just
annoying and disgusting we shouldn't
talk about it
but in fact emotions are there
nonetheless they are non-negotiable they
are physiological
if that i would argue that the the
baller thing to do the most
manly thing to do is to actually tune
in to the chaos of your own mind so that
you are not owned by it
and in the pro and that process if you
were to look at your shame your fat
your vanity your selfishness and be okay
with it be
have a warmer relationship to your own
ugliness which we all have
you would wear a mask right and it seems
like this
is now i want to start to get into the
path into my
mindfulness and meditation but in
getting to where
you eventually get or describe being at
the end of the book 10
happier you talk about this journey
through
you know the sort of woo that is that is
inherent in in some of these fields and
healing and wellness and all of this
different stuff and what i would
consider scammers although i don't know
that you
necessarily use that word in the book is
that
i mean from if you don't know anything
about
meditation and mindfulness and you've
just kind of gotten
two pictures of it one is that's for
girly men so to speak to take a kind of
meme that spreads
or it's woo you would probably be
predisposed to
to resist it as as many people do
yeah i think that's exactly right i
think that's probably why no not
probably
that is certainly why i was rejecting it
um initially because it i
because as i often say meditation has
been the victim of the worst marketing
campaign for anything
ever the traditional art around the
traditional depictions
of meditation you know show people
sitting on
you know top of a mountaintop you know
on the top of a mountain wearing loin
cloth with a beatific look on their face
etc etc that is not the experience of
meditation
for most people that i know for most
people that i know you can think about
meditation as a kind of exercise for the
brain
and for the mind where you are training
the mind in certain skills
and the the animating
insight for me the the thing i'm about
to tell you which
which was electrifying for me which is
why i've been doing
why i've been doing this practice
personally for more than a decade and
writing books about it and
having a podcast on it and having a
meditation app and blah blah blah
the reason i do all of this is because
what the science
is showing us the science uh the
scientific research into people who
meditate
is that the mind and the brain are
trainable that you are not stuck
with your characteristics like factory
settings that are
unalterable that the that happiness
compassion
generosity connection these are all
skills that can be trained
and that is a radical and empowering
notion
one of the things that i wonder if you
would agree can be tough for people
is everybody wants results and you want
to feel and see
results but this is like a really slow
moving thing it's sort of like
you know start a glacier moving a couple
of inches
a year or something like that and and i
wonder if in your experience
people abandoned their practice because
from day to day
or even month to month it doesn't really
feel like that much is necessarily
changing
yeah i think this is a big issue so uh
it is both slow and it's not so
uh for example i i've had this
uh when when my book first came out six
years ago my first book came out six
years ago i started saying this thing
which was meditate for a month every day
or daily-ish
and if by the end of that time you see
no benefit
send me a note on twitter and tell me
i'm a [ __ ] right people tell me i'm a
[ __ ] all the time
right but for other reasons maybe yes
never that
and so i do think that if you do it
consistently for a short for a few weeks
or a few months
you will notice that your inner weather
becomes bombier
you're not so yanked around by this
inner conversation that you are having
with yourself
which if we broadcast aloud you would be
locked up right
most of us aren't even aware that we
have this inner narrator this malevolent
puppeteer
that's you know giving us terrible ideas
all the time
so i actually do think you can derive
some of the advertised benefits of
meditation self-awareness
calm compassion focus in a few weeks
but but that take that that's that's
slower than the gym
um and over time it's very easy to
to to get into this mire where you're
thinking
oh okay i've been doing this for a year
but what what have my results been in
the last six months and
yes and that is when people do fall off
and i actually think there is
effects from falling off because when i
stop meditating for a couple of days
i notice that my inner atmosphere
becomes much more toxic
and that i'm much less likely to be able
to fend off the terrible ideas
served up to me by my inner narrator
like you know eat the 75th oreo or
say the thing that's going to ruin the
next 48 hours of your marriage or
whatever
and so i actually find that there is
real benefit to falling off
sometimes so in terms of of the simple
practice you know people you you don't
need to have
pay someone to give you a mantra you
don't need any specialized equipment i
mean for
to start it's really just about i mean
you can talk about how you did it but
it's just making a habit of
sitting for 10 minutes a day essentially
yeah so you should take what i say
on this score with a little bit of a
grain of salt because i am
co-proprietor of a meditation app so i
do believe
that there is some utility to
subscribing to meditation apps
but you don't need to use an app so
there are several ways you can get
started
importantly you didn't start with one i
did not that's exactly right
i started meditating before apps were a
thing right uh well
at least before meditation apps were a
thing yes uh 2009 i think
i read a book where i read a series of
books but i think the book the proximate
cause for my actually sitting down and
starting to meditate was a book by a
former molecular biologist
um by the name of john cabot zinn
called wherever you go there you are and
he described the
basic steps of mindfulness meditation
excuse me he described the basic steps
of mindfulness meditation very clearly
one sit in a reasonably comfortable
place and close your eyes
two bring your full attention to the
feeling of your breath coming in and
going out
three whenever you get distracted start
again
not super complicated now it can get
really interesting and complex in in
nice ways from there
hence the utility of reading books or
finding an
in-person teacher which is hard to do
during a pandemic
or using an app uh but
the basic instructions which i did on my
own for at least a year before i finally
went on a meditation retreat
uh are you know you could take what i
just told you and go for it
yep and uh that that book is sort of the
uh the classic that is the entry the
entryway for
for so many people yeah uh john cabin
teaching for a long time right down the
road from from us in worcester
massachusetts in fact at umass
medical center in worcester dan harris
author of
meditation for fidgety skeptics and the
book 10 percent happier
i really appreciate you uh sharing your
story with us dan
thanks for having me on the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your chemex or french
press or
a david pakman show t-shirt it's all
available
on our website shipping to anywhere in
the world
at davidpakman.com gear don't miss the
bumper stickers too
davidpakman.com forward slash gear
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
there's really no other way to introduce
this next clip
other than to tell you that when asked
about the exploding
coronavirus pandemic in the united
states yesterday
donald trump said obama and biden
stopped testing we're going to try to
figure out
what he meant but this is a man who is
disintegrating this is a man who
has collapsed this is a man who really
has nothing that he can say
because he has so mishandled coronavirus
that he's just muttering the name of his
predecessor at this point and uh is this
another brain glitch is this trump
trying to come up with
some new excuses to why he failed on the
virus and
you know we've joked that donald trump
is going to blame obama
for his coronavirus failures and he sort
of has
you know when trump says the cupboards
were bare that he means
we didn't have ventilators or ppe when
trump became
president now of course that's not true
but it's a weird critique because trump
had three years of presidency
before coronavirus hit during which he
could have refilled
those cupboards but putting that aside
in this clip trump is asked by cbs news
reporter
and friend of the david pakman show
weijia jiang
asked about the cases exploding and
trump
looks terrible and he says well obama
and biden stopped testing take a look
president trump you've said many times
that the number of
coronavirus cases is going up because
testing is increasing that's right
do you acknowledge that it's going up
for other reasons too
for example that it's actually spreading
and what are you going to do to stop the
spread
well you know that we have one of the
lowest mortality rates
anywhere if you know a biden and obama
stopped their testing they just stopped
it you probably know that i'm sure you
don't want to report it
but they stopped testing right in the
middle they just want
no more testing and uh on a
much lesser problem than the problem
that we have obviously with respect to
this is the worst thing that's happened
since probably 1917. this is very bad
all over the world 188 countries right
now
biden and obama stopped their testing
what is he talking about
in the middle of what like what what is
he actually referring to did trump
mean to say that was it some kind of
mental glitch
and i've been trying to be as charitable
as possible like what
does he mean that obama and biden
stopped ebola testing in 2014 that's
when we had four cases and two deaths
the ebola
pandemic in the united states it wasn't
even a pandemic globally but it was an
outbreak in the u.s it was four cases
and two deaths
is that what he's talking about obama
and biden stopped testing for something
we had four cases of
was he maybe referring to h1n1 which of
course was dramatically different and
everything about that
like what is trump talking about and in
fact yesterday he was particularly
incoherent during this event
here he is repeating their buying
they are buying over and over again just
another futile attempt by donald trump
to use language
china uh phase one deal's still intact
or is it uh do you see it in general
it's intact
it's intact but i'm uh i'm
i think what china has done to the world
with
what took place the china plague you can
go with the china virus you can call it
whatever you want to call it
it's about 20 different names what they
did
to the world should not be forgotten
but it's intact they're buying whether
they buy or not that's up to them
they're buying very sloppy and
you know i we said before when trump
aced
the montreal cognitive assessment that
it's no big deal
in watching this video i'm questioning
whether
he really could ace it i mean this is a
very
damaged individual here does does trump
know what city he's in when he's
answering these questions because this
is
bizarre behavior it can't be allowed to
continue
and it might unless we all get out and
vote
and that's what i need to talk to you
about next
donald trump's nightmare is now
potentially a reality
he is in a statistical tie with joe
biden
in the red state of texas
in an election which really could go
either way
in texas now i obviously don't have to
tell you
if joe biden were to win texas
this will be a historic defeat for
donald trump this will be like something
we've not seen
in a very long time in american politics
but i also shouldn't have to tell you by
now but i will
that nothing is certain and everyone
must vote so
in one new poll from texas from the
dallas morning news joe biden is now
leading by five
48-43 now that's leaving nine percent
in the third party or undecided bucket
uh and they could break for the
incumbent donald trump between now and
november and they may
well will they may well do that if you
look at the averages
of recent polling in texas it's not as
bad for trump in the real clear politics
average
it's just a tie in the 538 average
trump is ahead by 0.1 percent so
understand that these are blended
averages looking at recent polls
i don't know that the exact numbers are
so important like
if it's a tie in texas versus if trump's
winning by 0.1
or if trump or biden are winning by one
the point is it's close in texas and the
story is the trend line
three four months ago at the start of
the pandemic
five months ago now um trump was solidly
ahead in every texas poll
by about five points that lead has
evaporated
into what is now listen we can just say
it's tight in texas
now if you say to me david you've got to
bet money who wins texas in november i'm
still betting trump wins texas and in
fact
if you look at the betting market 64
percent of people
are still betting that donald trump wins
the state of texas but 64 percent is
actually quite low historically
because the last time that a democratic
presidential candidate
won in texas was jimmy carter
in 1976 that's 44 years ago so
this could be a historic defeat for
donald trump
or trump might suppress just enough of
the vote lie
and claim just enough of an
accomplishment
i guess on coronavirus or the economy to
convince
just enough people to vote for him just
enough people might end up deciding to
stay home
if vote by mail isn't happening in their
state and they feel that it's dangerous
to their health to go out and vote
and he could squeak out another
electoral win now
i want to be crystal clear about
something here
the nightmare of trump getting crushed
in november
will be nothing for him compared to the
nightmare
that he has subjected the united states
and the world to
for the last three and a half years and
trump may not have the nightmare of
losing in november
if we don't go vote and we get voters
registered
and we make sure that everybody votes so
this is the the daily or weekly reminder
you've got to vote no matter what ask
your friends if they are voting and
encourage
them to do so we do not want 2016
all over again now texas is interesting
for another reason
texas is a story as much about
gerrymandering as it is about
donald trump not doing well when you
look at the districts
texas is red there's no denying it but
texas is much less red than many other
states so for example
hillary clinton got 43 percent of the
vote in 2016
in texas 43 of the vote for comparison
here in massachusetts donald trump only
got 32 percent
of the vote so to put it a different way
hillary clinton's support in texas
was more than a third larger than trump
support
here in massachusetts texas is much more
purple
than many other states that are
considered solid red states
the thing about texas is that it is
hugely gerrymandered and when you look
at
the house reality uh in the u.s house of
representatives when you look at
the districts within texas at the state
level
the gerrymandering that has gone on
there is responsible for texas
seeming much more red than it actually
is because 43
for the democratic candidate in a state
that is
considered to be one of the reddest of
red texas is increasingly purple you
look at places like austin and other
cities it is a changing landscape and
let's see what we can do in 2020 to make
it
maybe the start of the start of um texas
being a
swing state texas being a battleground
state which would be terrible at a
systemic level for republicans as we've
talked about many many times
but assume nothing imagine that your one
vote
could be the deciding vote in your state
if you knew that
could be the case you would sure as hell
go out and vote
we've got an interesting voicemail today
the phone number to call
is 2192davidp this voicemail has what i
guess is now the requisite
podcast playing in the background pause
the show to call in remember you can
just hit pause
and then call me and then resume but in
any case you'll hear my voice in the
background
let's take a listen to this voicemail
hey david i was just wondering uh what
are your thoughts on
if president trump was to lose the
election
and he doesn't want to leave office what
do we do
listen um don't worry about that
okay there's a couple different things
there number one don't put the cart
before the horse
let's defeat trump first before we worry
about whether he'll leave office that's
the most important thing
because if we focus too much on what
will happen
if trump refuses to leave office trump
might get himself reelected and we don't
want that that's number one so just go
vote
number two if donald trump loses in
november
on january 21 2021 he will no longer be
the president of the united states
he just will not be the president okay
that's the way that it is written in the
law
and i am not particularly worried about
donald trump
successfully not turning over power to
joe biden
if he loses in november i do believe
trump will
claim that it was rigged i do believe
that it is
likely that many trumpists could be
moved
to get on the streets possibly with guns
if donald trump convinces them
that it was rigged and that really
donald trump won i i believe all of that
that could
well happen but trump will leave
because he will not be the president
anymore on january 21st
now i know that there are some
hypotheses floating around
here's what trump could do to prevent
this from going to joe biden in january
uh if indeed he were to lose most of
those scenarios actually lead to the
speaker of the house becoming president
it's important to understand
it doesn't mean there is not some
hypothetical scenario that you could
dream up of some way trump could remain
in the white house
i don't worry about voting right now
okay that's the important thing we've
got three and a half months until
november
let's win first then we'll have two more
two and a half more months
to make sure donald trump vacates the
white house and we'll deal with that
after november 3rd if that comes up
let's just leave it there
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we are going to talk about the u.s
budget deficit where are the deficit
hawks they're very very quiet as the u.s
budget deficit
has hit another all-time high
disney world is also offering mask-free
relaxation zones i will discuss
how much would i have to be paid to go
to disney world right now
not how much would i pay would i go with
it how much would i have to be paid to
go
and we are also going to talk about
china announcing some sanctions
against marco rubio and ted cruz two
republican senators
retaliatory sanctions against them all
of those stories and more
on today's bonus show don't miss it
become a member at joinpackman.com